Geht's wieder?
Ich glaube, es geht wieder.
Ja.
Oder vorne zugeschlagen, Leute.
Oder vorne zugeschlagen.
Die haben gesagt, nope, jetzt wird nicht gestreamt.
Streamen overrated, outdated, cheap baited.
Geil.
Warte mal kurz, was gucken in meinen E-Mails.
Okay.
So.
Wieder am Start.
Oder vorne.
Geht's jetzt?
Hat's geruckelt nochmal, Leute?
In den letzten paar Minuten?
Gut, ich hab nix gemacht.
Man hat nur den Chat gesehen.
Da ruckelt natürlich auch nix.
So, also, wo sind wir denn stehen geblieben?
Hier.
Bei der neuen Option für Stores.
Ach, man sagt jetzt Dollar.
Man sagt jetzt nicht Dollar-Blub.
Man sagt jetzt Dollar-Count oder so, ne?
Ist not a store with a subscribe method.
Aber wie macht man das denn jetzt?
Ach, man schreibt einfach nur.
Nur Blub-Count oder was?
Ah.
Okay, das kann das Autocomplete noch nicht.
Not a number.
Warum?
Muss es Const sein?
Warum ist es not a number?
Vielleicht kann man Plus-Plus jetzt nicht da drauf verwenden.
Weil Count ja ein Setter ist oder so.
Muss ich jetzt sagen Count.
Plus gleich 1 oder so?
Ne, äh, Moment.
JavaScript.
Geht das?
Ne, das funzt auch nicht.
Also, aber sowieso Count gleich 1 wird funktionieren.
Ja, das funzt.
Okay, das heißt, dann braucht man die lange Variante von.
Cancel.
Äh?
By the way, warum ist das überhaupt?
Was?
Und warum steht da nicht 1 drinne?
Ich sag doch hier explizit.
Create user state 1.
Ah.
Initial.
Punkt User Name.
Das ist ein Objekt, was der erwartet.
Also eigentlich will ich sowas hier haben.
Äh, jetzt funktioniert das auch.
Was das hier macht, check ich noch nicht so ganz.
Wäre Objekte oder so.
Das brauchen wir an der Stelle.
Geht das jetzt mit plus plus?
Jetzt geht es auch mit plus plus.
Okay, gut.
Also das ist quasi jetzt der Store-Ersatz.
Wir können jetzt mal kurz checken, ob das mit dem Store, ob das so funktioniert.
Denn wir gehen jetzt mal, wir zeigen das jetzt einfach mal nicht hier an.
Sondern zeigen das in unserer Kekkel-Component an.
Ja.
Die kriegt jetzt...
Den...
Jaja, den muss ich jetzt erst noch importieren.
Ja, Moment.
Wie greife ich denn jetzt von der anderen Komponente da drauf zu?
Weil da gibt es ja Plupp gar nicht.
Wie mache ich denn das jetzt?
Kann ich einfach...
Kann ich einfach hier auf...
Also bei meinem Store hätte ich jetzt gesagt Dollar.
Aber das ist es ja nicht.
Moment, der hat Probleme, weil es die Datei nicht gibt.
Moin Michael, 5 Spiele an.
Ja, das funktioniert so nicht.
Ja, beim Store hätte ich jetzt sowas davor gemacht, aber das funzt ja hier jetzt nicht.
Aber ich meine einfach jetzt hier Count schreiben, wird es doch nicht tun, oder?
Man muss das im Kontext setzen.
Ja, das ist...
Das muss anders gehen.
Das musstest du bei einem Store auch nicht.
Du würdest gerne eine Web-App erstellen, die keine dauerhafte Internetverbindung benötigt.
Du kannst alles verwenden dafür.
Oder du meinst so Sachen wie Offline-State.
Und Sync und so.
Boah, das habe ich noch nie gemacht.
Weil du kannst das natürlich manuell machen.
Irgendwie in Local Store und so schreiben.
Das weiß ich nicht.
Gute Frage.
Nächste Frage.
Habe ich noch nicht gemacht.
Also ich gehe mal davon aus, du willst sowas haben wie...
Wenn du dann mal wieder online gehst, dann die neuesten Sachen abholen, updaten und so.
Keine Ahnung.
Also damit bin ich noch nicht so ganz glücklich mit den Stores, wie es hier ist.
Mit dem Store-Ersatz.
Kann ja nicht sein, dass ich jedes Mal den Store irgendwie über Kontext rumpassen muss oder sowas.
Das hat mich schon nicht komplett überzeugt.
Ja, wie gesagt, mit Stores war das easy.
Die hast du einfach importiert und konzentriert drauf zugreifen.
Also so funktioniert das schon immer nett.
Und müssen wir mal weiter gucken.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, wie nennt sich das denn jetzt hier?
Svelte 5 Stores.
Guck mal mal, was die dazu schreiben.
Ja, Store.
Ja, man hat noch hier irgendwie...
Old vs. New Examples.
Gibt's da nix zu?
Cunchens vielleicht?
Store?
Da steht...
Da gibt's doch keine Docs dazu.
Checkout Component Party, ja.
Wann soll das rauskommen?
Irgendwann 2024.
Doomswap.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Irgendwann 2024.
Irgendwann dieses Jahr.
Mario, danke für den Sub.
Ah nee, das war gestern.
Hab ich gesehen, aber trotzdem.
Pog.
Im Jahr des Linux-Desktops.
Ja, richtig.
Ja, so ganz schlau werde ich da noch nicht draus.
Das muss ich mir mal ein bisschen näher angucken,
wie man damit Stores gescheit ersetzen kann.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch?
Form-Inputs.
Gibt ja einen Unterschied.
Außer State, ich nett.
Checkbox, Radio-Button.
Ja, ja, ist ja gut.
Das müssen wir uns nicht...
Web-App-Feature.
Hä?
Ach so, weil man Standalone verwendet.
Fetch-Data.
Das müssen wir uns auch nicht angucken.
Router-Link.
Okay, das war die Übersicht.
Also da...
Mit Store-Ersatz, das muss ich mir tatsächlich noch mal angucken.
Da bin ich so noch nicht...
Noch nicht ganz glücklich mit.
Also die Store-Syntax funktioniert ja so schon.
Keine Ahnung.
Leute, ich hab Hunger.
Ich muss jetzt was essen.
Wir haben zwei Möglichkeiten.
Ups.
Gibt es ein 4-Jahres...
Ich glaube, wir haben...
Nee.
Ich glaube, das Höchste, was es gibt, ist, glaube ich, der Goldkeks.
Ich müsste echt ein paar neue machen lassen.
Es sind Leute schon so lange dabei, teilweise.
Wir haben mal Zeit für neue Kekse.
Ekelst du eins?
Ja, du kannst gar nicht erwarten, ich weiß.
Magst du sagen, für den Sub?
Brauchen wir mal ein paar gute Ideen für...
Du kriegst dann das Wubblos Cert.
Wubblos Certified Professional.
WCP bist du dann.
Das wird überall international hoch geratet.
Das Wubblos Zertifikat.
Also so viel haben wir jetzt noch nicht ausprobiert, aber ich muss sagen,
nach meiner anfänglichen Skepsis, die ich hatte, als sie das hier im Artikel da rausgebracht haben,
muss ich sagen, ich finde fast alle Sachen nice, was ich bisher gesehen habe.
Ich bin sogar versucht, mal zu sagen, wir bauen irgendwie ein kleines Beispiel,
wie so eine Mini-Beispiel-Web-Anwendung mal,
mit so ein paar Komponenten und nicht wirklich viel Zeug drin.
Und mal mit Svelte 5, um mal wirklich sich die Unterschiede anzugucken.
Ja, blöd, dass der Stream abgekackt ist, so kurz vor Schluss.
Ich gehe jetzt aber was essen, Leute.
Ich bleibe nicht on dabei.
Ich kann einfach entspannter futtern, wenn Community-Girn nicht am Start ist dabei.
Und wir hören uns die Tage.
Ja, Leute, bis dann. Macht's gut.
See you.
Tschüss.